Six one seven eight three zero
4750 is the number. Let's go to our caller from 972 who's been holding on for a while who's there at nine seven two?
Hello, this is Tanner in Dallas. And I was wondering if there could be any evidence in the Trump Russia investigation
that could be so damning and so overwhelming that not only it could force a
impeachment but maybe even an early presidential election, uh a
presidential election
I think the answer is no but let's talk about the first one which is could what what evidence if it came out?
Would force an impeach so Tanner, let me ask you this. Do you mean something?
That's so bad that even a Republican House and Senate moves to impeach and then convict Trump or do you mean not necessarily?
a Republican house in the Senate I
think it would be I think both parties would
What could be so bad?
That no one in the House and Senate can say this guy needs to stay. I
Think no
I mean I can in that everything I have it would have to be so bad as to be
Cartoonish where I'm almost like embarrassed to say how bad it would be
Yeah, I also think that if there had some kind of direct connection maybe money connection that pump that
Putin paid Trump directly or maybe personal cash like Newton gave money
Yeah, Trump like a cycle of a bull years old or something like that
You know even that I feel like they'd figure out a way to say this is totally totally legal
This is there's nothing wrong with us whatsoever. We're making deals if there were tapes there would be doctored case
I also wanted to break up the early presidential election idea because I got a thinkin. Yeah, I don't think so that
You don't think so. Well, like I just don't think it would just be pens takes over and he and
He wants and he thinks that there could be a possibility for that
So sorry, I think for a fact from him yet, but I think it would be really interesting to see
That's really unprecedented
Yeah. All right. Well, we'll keep an eye on that
I think we're having a very unusual action issue, but I do appreciate the call and we will
Investigate any and all of these questions if you're holding on please don't hang up
We will take more calls after a quick break don't hang up if you're holding on we are taking more calls